donc cette primaire populaire qui devait
réunir la gauche les gauches pour
l'instant c'est raté marion libre aux
personnes arrivées en tête et madame
christiane taubira avec une mention bien
plus christiane taubira remporté donc la
primaire populaire et ses premiers mots
sont un appel à l'union de la gauche il
n'y a rien qui nous empêche de nous
parler de discuter d'aboutir à des
compromis et de gouverner ensemble il
n'y a rien
une main tendue rejeté illico presto par
les autres candidats yannick jadot jean
luc mélenchon anne hidalgo n'ont pas
prévu de la rejoindre ils ne
reconnaissent toujours pas la légitimité
de ce scrutin là on file et la chaussure
qui avait été préparé pour elle je suis
pas concerné j'ai été inscrits d'office
dans une élection à laquelle je ne
voulais pas participer c'est une
candidature de plus je crois que c'était
exactement l inverse de ce que
souhaitait la primaire populaire je les
dis comme d'autres ne me sentais pas
engagé non absolument et je continuerai
comme je les dis avant d'ailleurs cette
campagne plus de 390 mille électeurs se
sont exprimés lors de cette primaire et
pour l'ancienne garde des sceaux de
françois hollande cette participation
doit être entendue puis une candidate de
plus pour celles et ceux qui considèrent
que un processus démocratique ça ne vaut
strictement à rien du tout que un demi
million de personnes qui s'inscrivent et
qui votent ça ne vaut rien du tout
mépris et peut-être un mot trop fort
mais cette façon de tenir quand même en
distance de façon hautaine un processus
démocratique
christiane taubira a prévu d'échanger
cette semaine avec chacun de ses
concurrents pour tenter de les rallier à
sa candidature mais premier revers ce
lundi la direction de campagne d'arnaud
montebourg annonce apporté son soutien à
anne hidalgo
et on tire les leçons de cette primaire
populaire avec mes invités pierre
chartier bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste daniel goldberg
bonsoir toi y'a mieux aussi responsable
de la mobilisation territoriale au sein
de l'équipe de christiane taubira pablo
pino binya bonsoir bonsoir
responsable éditorial de la revue
regards on est également avec gaël
sliman qui est avec nous en duplex
président cofondateur doxa bonsoir réel
bienvenue dans certains marrons soir à
tence et bien évidemment matthieu
croissandeau avait côté du terrorisme
poétique soit comme tous les lundis et
mercredis je vais redonner un chiffre
tient pour commencer c'est celui de la
participation à 7 à cette primaire 392
1738 votants ça fait 84 plus de 84 % de
participation on a regardé ça fait
presque le double des votants pour les
primaires europe ecologie les verts et
ee l'air réunit donc on peut se dire la
gauche je devrais là tout de suite
depuis hier soir à fêter sa
démonstration de force est pourtant
claire chartier moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'elle m'a paraît encore plus divisés
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou pas
d'ailleurs absolument oui d'ailleurs on
vient de voir avec les réactions avec
les réactions c'est assez patent
effectivement ce qui est déjà la preuve
le premier enseignement c'est que
christiane taubira ce voulez vous les
mettre toutes ses forces pour unir la
gauche c'est finalement elle a re
devient un problème elle a été en 2002
on vous dit elle redevient là puisque en
plus avec son score en fait elle en
quelque sorte elle suscite de nouveaux
tirs allemands parce qu'elle des classes
quand même les deux autres poids lourds
qui suivent ce qu'elle est quand même
largement devant donc yannick jadot cet
homme dont il ya quand même là quelque
chose qui s'exprime et ils vont bien
devoir on tenir compte même si eux ne
voulaient pas figurer dans cette
primaire donc la ja elle leur pose quand
même un problème évident et puis en plus
ce type de vote ce jugement majoritaire
il est quand même intéressant parce que
il a pour je ne sais pas si c'est pour
vocation en tout cas pour effet de
dégager un candidat qu'on dit de
consensus mais surtout de rassemblement
en fait donc là encore c'est à dire ce
score quand même assez massif même si on
sait que la consultation a aussi ses
limites puisque oui on va en parler
évidemment
participent quelque chose c'est un gros
gros caillou dans la chaussure qui
braillent peuvent faire ce qu'ils ne
veulent pas entendre qu'ils ne voulaient
pas participer là la nature même de
cette consultation dit des choses très
intéressés seront forcément et
évidemment les uns les unes et les
autres regardez les résultats de près
daniel goldberg se sait pas quand même
une victoire à la pyrrhus pour
christiane taubira mais même d'une mère
général pour ce courant pour ces gauches
la situation de la gauche et de
l'écologie n'est pas bonne mais les pas
bonnes depuis hier soir si la situation
avait été bonne si jean luc mélenchon
qui fait campagne depuis deux ans
yannick jadot fabien roussel anne
hidalgo qui font campagne depuis six
mois au mois de décembre s'il avait été
l'un ou l'autre l'une ou l'autre en
situation de l'emporter à l'élection
présidentielle voire même de sigur au
second tour ce qui n'est pas le cas ce
qui n'était pas le cas il n'y aurait pas
eu christiane taubira candidate et elle
l a déclaré sa disponibilité puis sa
candidature parce que la situation était
bloquée donc aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation je peux pas vous dire qu'elle
était bloquée alors mais néanmoins qu'en
quatre cent mille personnes
s'expriment quand c'est le double de la
participation ce que vous venez vous
même le dire d'autres consultations et
ses 105 milles pour écologie les verts
sans garantie d'autres candidats
allaient leur légitimité que sur le vote
de leurs propres troupes militantes de
leurs propres supporters qui est la
candidature en plus aujourd'hui ou qui
allaient candidature en mieux c'est
quand même ça la question et deuxième
point chacun d'eux des candidats et des
candidates qui sont tous respectables
ils ne se sont pas engagés pour porter
un fanion sont pas engagés pour les uns
pour défendre les couleurs du parti
communiste du parti socialiste d'europe
écologie ou des insoumis sont gagnées
ils se sont engagés pour essayer de
gagner une élection est donc pour
changer la vie de nos concitoyens et là
on resterait complètement bloquée sans
rien faire en se disant que l'élection
est dans dix semaines et que chacun va
poursuivre son chemin en n'ayant aucune
perspective de victoire je pense que ce
qui a été montré hier et je m'arrête là
dans cette première intervention ce qui
a été montré hier c'est une volonté de
quatre cent mille personnes pour celles
et ceux qui ont voté femmes et hommes de
gauche de l'écologie de reprendre en
main leur propre destinée oui mais il ya
quand même pas mal de choses à dire sur
l'organisation les conditions
d'organisation de ce scrutin est
peut-être le fait que cela biaise un peu
le vote de ceux qui ont participé je
vous poserai la question de cela on aura
le temps d'en dans des bas je voudrais
entendre pablo pino vie à quai comment
vous l'analysez qu'est ce qu'est ce que
vous faites ressortir est ce que
finalement c'est le succès de christiane
taubira l'humiliation quand même pour
anne hidalgo qui arrive qui arrive très
loin dans le temps dans les résultats
la première chose à mon avis qu'il faut
noter c'est un fait important c'est vous
l'avez rappelé et les 400000 personnes
inscrites en fait c'est un c'est un fait
politique il ya une c'est une
démonstration de force de la part des
organisateurs de la primaire populaire
ensuite je ne suis pas certain en fait
que ça octroie une légitimité à
christiane taubira dans la mesure où le
seul mandat pour l'instant qu'elle a eue
qui lui a été octroyé au travers de ceux
de ce vote un peu particulier c'est de
rassembler or aujourd'hui force est de
constater que ben le rassemblement je
suis désolé mais on a entendu les
différents candidats mais ça paraît très
très compliqué donc à la dic allait
passer donc savait avant le vote est
surpris après exactement donc pour
l'instant j'entends beaucoup de gens
dire ah non mais il faut attendre
maintenant taubira il va falloir qu'elle
nous dise quel est son projet quelles
sont ses propositions et c'est le
problème c'est que c'est pas pour ça en
fait que les gens ont voté pour elle
faire lui ont donné la mention qui lui
ont donné à la primaire populaire j lui
en donner pour qu'elle rassemble la
gauche pour qu'elle ne soit pas une
candidature en plus donc je trouve qu'il
ya une contradiction en fait dans les
termes et les saisons plus voter pour le
rassemblement plus que pour moi c'est ce
que je pense un petit mot et après juste
là il ya quelque chose d'assez
intéressant que que cas noté en fait
dans le vote à jugement majoritaire
c'est qu'en fait ça exclut certains des
candidats les plus clivants quand vous
regardez par exemple
et le nombre de mentions voir le
pourcentage qui se sont acquis sont
allés vers les mentions insuffisant
enfin les mentions du plus basse par
exemple pour un candidat comme jean luc
mélenchon elles sont assez importantes
parce que jean luc mélenchon en est un
candidat qui au sein de la grande
famille de la gauche est un candidat qui
clivent les gens disent bon bah moi je
préfère avoir christiane taubira yannick
jadot c'est assez original parce que
henri iv mais on pouvait me dire ça
aussi de christiane taubira qui a été à
ses clientes on aurait pu dire ça que
c'est un taux bien mais je pense aussi
qu'elle a bénéficié à beaucoup de gens
qui se sont inscrits à cette primaire
précisément parce que christiane taubira
ont ils été remis on a vu une
augmentation du nombre d'inscriptions à
partir du moment où elle a dit à la mi
décembre je voudrais participer à cette
primaire donc c'est sûr jean luc
mélenchon est un peu dur moi je suis un
peu gêné en fait parler les remarques un
peu méprisante de certains de certains
membres de certaines familles politiques
comme jean dupuy adjoint yannick jadot
et anne hidalgo qui balaie ça d'un
revers de main comme si ils n'allaient
pas le prendre en considération de leur
campagne je pense que c'est important
qu'ils qu'il voit qu'il ya une partie du
peuple de gauche alors c'est peut-être
pas grand-chose c'est quand même mais
c'est quand même quatre cent mille
personnes qui cherchent en fait qu'ils
sont perdus et qu'ils cherchent un
débouché et qui ont pensé que cette
primaire populaire ça aurait ça aurait
pu aboutir à quelque chose je pense que
ça va être un échec moi ça fait depuis
le début je sens je sens la chose venir
mais bon il met beaucoup de gens ont
beaucoup de commentateurs santa choses
venir et aujourd'hui je vois pas trop
comment christiane taubira va réussir à
se sortir en fait du nid de ronces dans
lequel elle s'est empêtrée j'ai donné la
parole tout de suite à gaël sliman parce
que vous aviez une sortie vendredi un
sondage sur ce que les sympathisants de
gauche attendaient de ces primaires je
le trouve assez édifiant ce sondage
pourquoi
il est édifiant parce qu'ils donnent
plutôt raison à monsieur goldberg tel
sentiment que la gauche est une sorte de
grand cadavre à la renverse que les
sympathisants de gauche depuis très
longtemps attendent une solution d'union
et il s'estimait et c'est ça qui est
intéressant avant le résultat du scrutin
il était une très large majorité
à nous dire qu'il souhaitait que les
candidats qu'ils ne gagneraient pas
cette primaire populaire se range
derrière le vainqueur ou celle qui
allait l'emporter et donc on peut bien
avoir les postures cohue anne hidalgo
ganic jadot ou jean luc mélenchon
rien ne dit qu'une partie des électeurs
qui pour le moment manifeste des
intentions de vote en leur faveur
continuerons de le faire dans les
prochains sondages d'intentions de vote
parce que du point de vue de l'ensemble
des sympathisants de gauche y compris
les insoumis un très largement y compris
les sympathisants écologistes et plus
encore les sympathisants socialistes il
ya cette idée que on ne peut pas être
ventilé façon cusm avoir finalement des
candidats 5 6% et et risquer une telle
bérézina l'enjeu n'est même pas de
savoir si cette primaire populaire
permettra à la gauche de gagner la
présidentielle
je sais pas si certains sympathisants le
souhaitent dans leurs rêves les plus
fous l'enjeu c'est de ne pas être
totalement ridicule parce que pour
l'instant la situation de la gauche elle
est
absolument ubuesque on arrive à un total
des voix 25 % alors je ne compte pas
emmanuel macron il ya tout un débat
là-dessus une partie de sympathisants
bouge vote pour lui mais il ya un total
des voix de gauche autour des 25% avec
aucun gros candidats vous n'avez pas un
candidat qui dépasse les 10% donc une
initiative comme comme la primaire
populaire évidemment qu'elle fait rêver
les sympathisants de gauche si c'était
seulement si ça permettait seulement ne
serait-ce que d'avoir une christiane
taubira qui boostait par ce succès
dépasse les 10% même si les autres
candidats restent en lice
mais ce serait déjà moins ridicule et ça
permettrait au peuple de gauche de se
dire qu'il existe encore et je pense que
ça va être très compliqué de faire comme
si de rien n'était alors peut-être moins
pour jean luc mélenchon qui est le
candidat plus fort aujourd'hui dans les
intentions de vote qui approche les 10%
et puis qui dès le départ avait annoncé
qu'il était là jamais entrouvert la
porte à une telle union mais je pense
que pour yannick jadot et surtout pour
anne hidalgo qui subit un terrible
camouflet avec ce score derrière pierre
larrouturou je pense que ce sera très
compliqué de se maintenir et qu'elle
peut très bien finir en dessous des 2%
dans les enquêtes et le jour du scrutin
on peut revoir d'ailleurs le ce résultat
ou surclassement de la primaire
populaire avec ces mentions en mention
bien plus pour christiane taubira assez
bien plus jadot assez bien moins pour
lille et lens ont ensuite on a
effectivement pierre larrouturou
passable plus anne hidalgo passable plus
charles autres marchandises passable -
et un hacker porterie pour qui c'est
insuffisant il n'y a pas eu suffisamment
de votes pour pour kalou à dirk claes
est ce ce résultat mathieu à quoi ça
sert en continue de se poser la question
ce soir alors d'abord c'est une
initiative citoyenne et dans un pays
qu'on dit fâché avec la politique nous
désespérer la politique c'est plutôt
respectable et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle ensuite et à la participation
s'élèverait à 3 192 mille personnes
c'est énorme mais contrairement aux jeux
olympiques important on n'est pas
forcément de participer au tout cas pas
seulement de participer à une primaire
et pour tirer les premiers enseignements
il faut se reposer la question de à quoi
ça sert au fond une primaire faut savoir
que longtemps les politologues ou ceux
où les élus qu'on cherchait à importer
ce modèle en france ont divisé en deux
modèles la primaire dit à l'américaine
qui est généralement organisé par un
parti et qui sert à sélectionner son
candidat c'est-à-dire à choisir entre
plusieurs prétendants celui qui aura
l'investiture puis avait un autre modèle
était la primaire à l'italienne or dire
des glaces mais voilà c'est comme ça est
généralement organisé par une coalition
ils n'ont pas parlé en partie et de et
dont le but était plutôt de propulser le
candidat dans la campagne et dû donner
un élan jusqu'au scrutin dans le premier
cas on a si souvent une bataille très
féroce on le voit en la vue en france
dans les prix mais on l'a vu aux renvois
aux états unis dans le second
l'essentiel c'est pas vraiment le
résultat en fait il est souvent que
d'une avance mais c'est plutôt la
mobilisation puis alors la soca hybride
de la primaire populaire où on s'agit
toutefois de mobiliser 2 partager mais
aussi de faire d'union sur une base
programmatique et autour d'un candidat
cerise sur le gâteau elle n'est pas
organisée par un parti ni par une
coalition mais par un collectif citoyen
ça aura au moins permis de désigner une
gagnante oui mais après il faut se pour
aller jusqu'au bout il faut se poser à
mon avis trompe enfin moi je me pose
dans le iv en question est ce qu'on va
gagner aux clarifications non malgré ses
victoires christiane taubira n'est pas
un vainqueur clair est unanimement
reconnu comme tel par par tout le monde
le mode de scrutin dit au jugement
majoritaire même s'il est intéressant il
est quand même très confus et très
obscur pour le profane au delà de son
petit côté butin scolaire par ailleurs
le casting était pour le moins bancale
puisque trois candidats sur sept ne
souhaitait pas participer à cette
primaire et n'ont donc pas fait campagne
il faut le savoir quand même sont pas
fait campagne et puis un autre a été je
pense à fabien aux ailes et sans que
personne ne comprenne bien pourquoi aux
besoins ce qui n'était pas arrivé dans
les dix premiers oui de leur propre
sélection mais géré quand le quand la
primaire se tient en pleine campagne
c'est quand même bancale deuxième chose
est ce qu'on a gagné en simplification
de l'offre politique non plus la gauche
que jamais été aussi faible aussi
émietté compte autant de candidats avant
qu'après le répète même pu en compter
davantage si arnaud montebourg n'avait
pas été bien inspiré vous n'avez pas eu
cet éclair de lucidité de de se retirer
puis enfin at-on gagnant proposition bat
toujours pas est d'ailleurs assez
révélateur que christiane taubira et été
jugée la plus apte à rassembler la
gauche et à faire gagner parce qu'elle
est quand même la volonté chez
organisateurs les organisateurs de faire
gagner l'écologie la justice sociale
alors quel seuil est présenté à cette
primaire sans aucun programme ou avec
très peu d'idées très très peu de
propositions donc c'est quand même très
paradoxal est alors une question qu'on
se pose est que on aura sans doute la
réponse dans les prochains jours c est
ce que ça peut lui donner un élan dans
dans les intentions de vote on a hâte de
le vérifier comme le disait guy simoneau
si jamais les porter au delà de 10 ça
aura été une réussite si ce n'est pas le
cas ça aurait été en fait je trouve
parce qu'elle était trop tardive trop
alambiqué cette primaire ça aurait été
une forme de ball-trap pour des
candidats qui étaient déjà installés
depuis plusieurs mois dans le rôle de
candidat avec les scores que l'on sait
mais tout ça aux bénéfices au service
d'une candidate qui se sera déclarée par
opportunité je n'ai pas par opportunisme
en tout cas par opportunité en faisons
le le calcul que personne personne ne
s'en sortaient et donc du coup elles
sont là on sera évidemment plus dans une
machine à perdre selon l'expression
consacrée qu'une et j'ai grillé et je
reprends votre votre expression de
ball-trap parce que c'est vrai que
daniel d'olbia c'est quand même moi je
pense que c'est le le principal si on se
place dans du côté de ses sympathisants
de gauche qui ont poussé à
l'organisation de cette primaire
populaire qui ont voté pour ces prières
populaire vous l'avez évoqué un peu tout
à l'heure il ya une fragilisation des
candidats qui étaient là précédemment
donc il ya un côté ball-trap janis et on
a dézingué 3d des candidats qui
installent des mois je ne sais pas moi
je n'emploierai pas cette expression
mais le dézingage si je la reprends
quand même un petit peu
il est fait tous les jours par les
sondages enfin je m'excuse mais on si on
considère que la primaire populaire
était une expression de 400 mille
personnes ce qui n'est quand même pas
négligeable donc de femmes et d'hommes
de gauche et de l'écologie qui ont
plutôt envie de voter pour un candidat
de gauche et de l'écologie qui à 85 % si
je me souviens bien de ce qu'a dit gaël
sliman souhaiterait une convergence de
ces familles là
ça s'est matérialisé de cette manière là
peut-être que christiane taubira l'a
emporté aussi je réagis est-ce que ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure parce
qu'elle était la seule à défendre le
fanion de l'unité justement à dire que
sa candidature elle s'inscrivait dans
une démarche unitaire et les réactions
que j'ai entendu effectivement assez
méprisante des autres candidats et
candidates hier soir et ce matin me font
dire que il risque une forme de punition
je vous le dis aussi en tout cas moi
c'est ce que j'ai entendu je fais des
déplacements et christiane taubira la
semaine dernière à grenoble à briand
sion dans la manifestation autour de
l'éducation nationale c'était très
puissant ce mouvement et cette question
qui est posée elle et pas seulement
poser à yannick jadot jean luc mélenchon
anne hidalgo et fabien roussel et pour
ma part si j'avais organisé la primaire
populaire j'aurais réintégrer fabien
roussel sur ce sujet là mais elle est
posée à tous les élus locaux de terrain
ceux qui sont dans leur ville dans leur
région dans leurs départements qui sont
aussi soutenus par des femmes et des
hommes de gauche qui cherche une fierté
qui cherchent à relever la tête qui
cherche aussi à montrer qu'on est dans
une possibilité d'exprimer des positions
je vais vous donner en parle mais je me
tourne vers gaël sliman parce que
à nous vous venez pour je ne sais quel
enjeu majeur certainement je n'en doute
pas gaël mais dans quelques minutes donc
je vous donne une dernière fois la
parole justement sur cette aztèque que
moi je trouve très intéressant la
fragilisation potentiel de ce qui je le
rappelle
n'était participer à cette primaire
contre leur volonté arrivent donc même
le fus je le redis c'est insupportable
c'est majeur voilà comme vous dites mais
qui pourrait la maintenant dans les
intentions de vote y perdre parce que il
refuse de se ranger à ses au résultat de
cette primaire c'est 400 mille personnes
qui sont exprimés ah ben c'est certain
mais là pour le coup ce n'est pas de la
faute de la primaire populaire ou de
houe de christiane taubira il ya une
insatisfaction chez les électeurs de
gauche à avoir autant de candidats qui
se présentent et qui ne parviennent pas
à convaincre il ya une demande d'unité
et moi je ne serais pas étonné si
pleurer si les médias parlent en nombre
et c'est ce qui commence à être fait du
résultat de cette primaire peut plaire
je serais pas du tout étonné qu'on
assiste à un effondrement de la plupart
de la plupart de ces candidats il ne
possède pas quelque chose que les hommes
politiques ont du mal à a vraiment
intégré il ne possède en aucun cas leurs
électeurs les électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon n'appartiennent pas à jean luc
mélenchon et les électeurs de papus que
les éducateurs de yannick jadot ou de
anne hidalgo et à partir du membres tous
ses lecteurs tous et électorale a pour
les trois quarts d'entre nous disait
cette initiative me paraît bonne
j'aimerais bien que le candidat fut-il
un candidat qui n'était pas le mien
initialement qui l'emportent se voit
rallier par les autres partir du moment
où ils seront frustrés de voir cela ça
pourra avoir un effet alors on ne suis
pas devin je ne sais pas si cet effet se
matérialisera et à quel point mais
encore une fois si jamais on avait une
christiane taubira autour des 10 % dans
les sondages dans les dix quinze jours
qui viennent et bien dans ce cas-là
mécaniquement sa aspirerait complètement
les autres candidatures si ce n'est pas
le cas on aura toujours une christiane
taubira à 5 6% une année alcoa 2 3% un
mélenchon elles disent rien n'aura
changé
ce ne sera pas bien pire qu'avant donc
mon sentiment c'est que cette primaire
populaire elle ne pourra pas faire plus
de mal à la gauche que la gauche ne s'en
était déjà fait question subsidiaire il
ya encore quoi peut-être un électeur sur
deux qui sait pas pour qui si vale
volume pour qui va aller voter est ce
que depuis elle a un réservoir de voix
qui pourrait se porter vers qui
s'inspirera sans forcément affaiblir les
autres
alors je pense que oui il ya un
réservoir de voix qui pourraient aller
vers pourquoi pas christiane taubira
mais je pense qu'il ya des mécaniques
des fluides qui agissant en terme
d'opinion et que si jamais il ya une
aspiration sur christiane de bien c'est
que les gens sont grégaires aux motos
nier c'est qu'ils se diront bombe à
celle qui a le plus de chance de bien
faire figurer la gauche c'est celle qui
à la lan cependant qui est dans une
posture ascendante et donc à la
récupérera mécaniquement dans ce cas là
des voix des autres candidats et
honnêtement comprendre pourquoi anne
hidalgo persiste en étant à 2 3% c'est
un mystère et pourquoi le parti
socialiste s'obstine aussi à vouloir
aller droit dans le mur parce que une
élection présidentielle où on aurait un
score de moins de 5% pour le ps c'est ce
serait catastrophique pour le parti pour
ses comptes et derrière pour les
élections législatives qui suivront
merci elle bonne soirée à vous merci à
cette première partie du débat on va
reparler d'anne hidalgo mais je voudrais
vraiment qu'on soit encore sur la
l'organisation finalement claire
chartier parce que c'est moi je me mets
imaginons moi je vais pas aller voter
pour un candidat qui a dit je veux pas
participer au à la primaire j'ai pas
fait campagne pour cette primaire donc
le résultat je pense il est biaisé parce
que les autres candidats un peu majeur
connu du grand public n'ont pas fait
campagne la grande faille de cette
consultation c'est ça en plus c'est une
idée de contraintes qui va complètement
à l'encontre de l'idée la démocratie
enfin il ya une espèce de hiatus mais
sur le fond la remarque qui vient d'être
fait me semble très intéressante à
propos des partis qui pensent encore
posséder leurs électeurs je trouve que
la réaction qu'ils ont aujourd'hui c'est
parti ces derniers temps est assez
symptomatique de ce qui se passe parce
que ces primaires en fait elles elles
résultent de travaux qui sont menés
depuis des mois donc les partis ont été
les consultées etc ils n'ont pas voulu
collaborer et en fait là au travers de
cette démarche là il ya quand même une
mise sous pression des structures
partisanes traditionnelles et on voit
que ces structures partisanes elles ne
veulent pas évoluer quand même parce que
encore une fois il ya quand même la
nouveauté c'est pas du côté des partis
aujourd'hui qu'elle surgit c'est du côté
de la base citoyenne alors avec tous les
défauts qu'on vient dénoncer et qui aura
peut-être été moindre si les parties
avaient joué le jeu par ailleurs donc il
ya quand même une dans l'ingénierie
politique démocratique donc ça se passe
du côté des citoyens les partis ne
veulent pas l'entendre les parties
considèrent encore que leurs électeurs
leur appartiennent donc on a là je
trouve l'illustration de la difficulté
de la classe politique dont au sens
large pas simplement de la gauche là
pour le coup a passé finalement à
prendre la mesure de l'évolution de la
société ou dans laquelle on nous sommes
dans une société où où la médiation
partisane elle joue beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui les gens s'expriment tout
seul ils n'ont pas besoin de
représentants de jour de la page après
mais pablo
publie un pardon finalement est-ce que
c'est la démonstration d'un fossé qui
est encore en train de se creuser un peu
plus ce qu'on vit là depuis depuis
quelques jours est ce qu'on va vivre
dans les prochains jours avec le les
leçons tirées de ceux de cette primaire
populaire un fossé qui se creuse entre
les citoyens et les partis politiques je
suis pas certain j'aimerais juste
revenir sur ce que vous venez de dire
parce que les partis politiques ont
participé à l'élaboration du socle
commun dans la primaire populaire alors
ils s'en sont du douanier ils sont
sortis ils ont commis quelques mois
c'est extrêmement ambigu moi je pense
que l'erreur en fait ça vient de là déjà
ils ont cherché le plus petit
dénominateur commun et je pense que
c'est une erreur c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait de la politique je pense que
le ver était dans le fruit à partir du
moment où les organisateurs de la
primaire citoyenne les citoyens en fait
qu'ils se sont sentis investis de cette
mission de réunir la gauche on imaginer
que par l'intermédiaire par le
truchement unique d'un outil parce que
ça reste juste un outil cette plateforme
il allait pouvoir résoudre tous les
problèmes qui traverse les différentes
sensibilités de la gauche aujourd'hui il
ya des divergences à gauche des
divergences qui sont importantes sur des
sujets majeurs il ya des différences à
la fois dans le projet c'est à dire que
honnêtement anne hidalgo ne rêve pas de
la même france que jean luc mélenchon
etc ils sont issus de courants fin où il
représente plutôt aujourd'hui des
courants politiques qui sont
sensiblement différent et surtout les
propositions qu'ils entendent mettre en
avant sont différentes je vous si vous
prenez le nucléaire si vous prenez la
question de la retraite il ya énormément
de
moi je suis je suis intimement persuadé
que la politique c'est de là confie
qualité et mais la compliquent a été
apaisée et qu'il n'y a que comme ça en
fait qu'on peut résoudre les problèmes
que ça soit à gauche mais ça marche
aussi pour tout le pays et imaginez
qu'une course de petits chevaux parce
que tout à l'heure c'est intéressant
vous avez dit la primaire à l'américaine
c'est ils choisissent l'incarnation
finalement qui leur sied le plus mais
c'est pas que ça les incarnations en
fait derrière il ya des courants
politiques je veux dire entre joe biden
et bernie sanders il avait des
propositions différentes pour la france
ils se sont affrontés sur cette base là
et ensuite ils ont composé ils ont
cherché
un crédit se poser aujourd'hui ils ont
un peu de mal à
medan ça arrive influent a influencé la
politique menée pendant depuis un an par
l de joe biden et c'est assez
intéressant et le syncrétisme n'a pas
été rendue possible par cette primaire
populaire alors sur la primaire comme
tout à l'heure sur est ce que finalement
on luttait pas biaisé parce que on est
en train de commenter une victoire de
christiane taubira et ce à des
concurrents qui ont passé quand bien il
ya qu'est ce que vous direz si on pas
fait kampala ils ont refusé ils ont pas
non maintenant qu'ils renault visait à
la meute et non me dites pas qu'ils
n'ont pas fait campagne parce qu'ils
étaient sur toutes les chaînes de télé
et deux ténors je suis pas d'accord
lundi parce que quand on est
terminée
quand on s'inscrire on s'assure
n'étaient pas d'accord sur moi c'est
voter pour quelqu'un qui dit je suis pas
d'accord pour le processus elle se fait
contre mon gré et je fais pas campagne
mais il est convaincu d'abord si jamais
l'un ou l'autre l'avait emporté hier
est-ce que vous pensez que toutes ces
critiques elle serait toujours valable
si yannick jadot l'avait emporté hier 6
jean luc mélenchon l'avait emporté hier
puisque c'est ceux qui sont arrivés 2e
ou 3e je pense que ces critiques
auraient été bien amoindrie aujourd'hui
premier était très faible si la
compagnie mais christiane taubira n'a
pas fait campagne pour la primaire elle
a fait campagne en se disant je
m'inscris dans le processus parce que je
recherche l'unité avant tout première
chose deuxième chose ils ont fait
campagne sur leur proposition ça fait
des mois que leurs propositions sont sur
la table et yannick jadot samedi encore
présentait son projet à lyon est
d'ailleurs christiane taubira je pense
qu'elle a présenté sa démarche mais elle
a aussi présenté des propositions
notamment en direction de la jeunesse et
que ça a marqué beaucoup le fait de se
dire on a besoin d'investir dans notre
jeunesse quand on a les cils alimentaire
devant les écoles et pour revenir devant
les étudiants pardon pour revenir sur ce
que vous disiez que je partage tout à
fait qu'est ce qu'on a vécu depuis
plusieurs années en france on a vécu je
mets de côté les violences le mouvement
des gilets jaunes et qu'une éruption
citoyenne de revendications or partis
politiques et celles et ceux qui ont
voulu un filtre et se mettre dedans ne
l'ont pas lu on a eu le mouvement me to
or formation politique on a eu la marche
sur le climat et la convention citoyenne
qui en a suivi or formation politique
est là aujourd'hui on a effectivement
des femmes et des hommes 2 gauche qui
ont organisé et encore une fois j'aurais
eu à l'organiser moi même peut-être que
j'aurais fait des choses différentes
mais qui se sont dit on mène ce
processus et d'autres qui se sont dit on
se sert de cet instrument et donc il
faut que les formations politiques sous
peine d'être complètement discrédité et
moi ce n'est pas mon souhait elles
entendent cela et elle elle en tiennent
compte mathieu non moi je trouve qu'on
peut célébrer le renouveau démocratique
citoyen les meilleurs populaire faut pas
non plus être complètement naïf parce
que ce renouveau formidable renouveau
démocratique il aboutit à quoi ils
abouti avec une candidate qui fait
partie du paysage politique depuis de
très nombreuses années il ya déjà été
candidate à la présidentielle décide
porté par un parti qui trouve là un trou
de souris dans lequel il est bien
content de pouvoir sans ce s'engouffrer
le parti radical de gauche qui ne
pouvait pas présenter de candidats
appelés on sait que ça se finisse comme
ça quand même avec une candidate à
gauche et personne d'autre et j'entends
bien mais avec moi c'est quelqu'un de
l'action et et charlotte marchandises
corps était élu là on pourrait dire
quelle incroyable renouveau démocratique
citoyen c'est quand même une figure
gélise une vieille figure c'est pas une
figure installés depuis longtemps dans
le paysage politique qui tire les
marrons du feu et tout ça à vous disiez
oui c'est la seule qui parle d'unité
mais enfin elle ne parle que d'unité
derrière elle non avec elle et ça change
tout oui ça change tout sens mais parce
que ceux ci changent c'est un jeu de
mots
n'envisage pas un n'aurait pas envisagé
de faire l'unil l'union où l'unité avec
jean luc mélenchon serait bien sûr que
si puisqu'elle avait accepté le résultat
de la primaire eh bien oui mais là non
plus ça ne lâche jamais bien sûr que
s'ils ont lentement mais bien sûr la
tonnelle l'appel
si vous faites si
on a une figure installé
je ne retirerai pas puisque c'est là
dessus sur ce verbe la queue que l'on
discute et ça signifie que justement si
ça n'était pas elle qui l'emportait elle
se mettrait au service du candidat ou de
la candidate qu'il est c'est-à-dire
comme la condition ses provisions
je trouve ça quand même aussi quelque
chose d'intéressant tour de kristen
tombe bien elle même parce qu'elle
incarne quelque chose est la gauche
précisément d'ailleurs la france
insoumise et d'autre les verts au moment
des européennes lui avait fait des
avances pressantes donc elle incarne à
gauche dans toute la famille politique
de gauche quelque chose et là aussi à
mon sens c'est quelque chose qui
s'exprime parce qu'ils ne sont qu on est
dans un moment où alors certes on a
besoin de mesures de programme on est
dans une campagne mais on a aussi besoin
d'intensité et d'affirmation identitaire
donc à droite on a un candidat qui est
eric zemmour qui a des convictions on
les partage ou pas mais absolument
chevillée au corps et qui aime bien
aussi elle incarne sa de l'autre côté
c'est quand même celle qui a claqué la
porte au moment de la du débat sur la
déchéance de nationalité c'est celle qui
a porté par dont un peu après à
l'ambition mois sortira pas du tout
parce que j'étais parlementaire
souvenirs dans la mémoire collective
c'est elle c'est aussi elle une forme
d'or c'est une forme de l1 car oui enfin
elle surtout non elle incarne une
identité je pense que pour pour pas mal
de gens à gauche elle incarne quelqu'un
qui a des convictions des convictions
bien enraciné à gauche et je pense que
c'est aussi ça la fait jean luc
mélenchon yannick jadot et jean luc
mélenchon problème c'est qu'il a dit la
république c'est moi donc sa flamme
c'est sa flamme qui effectivement été
superbe et elle a quand même beaucoup
diminué parce qu'il est allé un peu trop
loin dans ses convictions auxquelles
elle n'a pas commis ce faux pas là donc
j'ai appelé vacciner affaire l'a commise
hors
en disant que ça n'a rien à voir avec la
république c'est moi comme alors une
responsabilité collective importante
toujours dit que non je veux bien qu'on
revienne là-dessus elle a toujours dit
que le vaccin était la solution et elle
a toujours dit qu'il ne suffisait pas de
dire aux gens d'aller se faire vacciner
pour qu'ils aillent se faire vacciner et
qu'on arrive je refuserai de le déloger
vous savez moi d'appeler ça se fait avec
vous il ya des nuls
et on est à lyon on wheels exactement où
j'ai été particulièrement urgent
département de seine-saint-denis on sait
bien que pour la vaccination il faut
entamer de l'allée vers les populations
s'est passé pas nos débats jours à venir
vous l'avez évoqué c'est évidemment sur
la précédente candidature de christine
taubira à la présidentielle 2002
rappelle du score du premier tour 2,32 %
des voix ce mauvais souvenir et est il
en train de de toquer à la porte du
subconscient de christiane taubira lors
de son discours de victoire hier soit on
peut pas s'en empêcher écouter le lapsus
[Applaudissements]
ma cheville ouvrière d'une possible
victoire en avril 2002
possible victoire en avril deux
évidemment elle s'en est rendu compte
elle en a plaisanté quelques minutes
plus tard mais quand même si si on fait
un petit ange et un petit regard dans le
rétro pablo pino vient il ya 20 ans avec
jean pierre chevènement parce que aussi
le jospin était trop confiant dans son
bilan bref enfin il ya ben y'a plein de
bonnes raisons pour expliquer le
résultat du premier tour en 2002 mais
quand même elle avait participé à la
division 2 de la gauche à l'époque c'est
c'est quand même le spectre la bis
repetita que les sympathisants ont aussi
en tête à mon avis moi c'est pas
tellement comme ça que je l'analyse mois
la longue la longévité politique de
christiane taubira j'ai plutôt envie de
l'apprécier à l'aune de la philosophie
et de en fait de ce qu'elles portent
compte à l'heure vous parliez de valeur
c'est intéressant parce que c'est pas la
seule en fait à avoir des valeurs et
avoir une histoire d'ailleurs elle je
sais pas trop en fait dans quelques
courants de la gauche exactement elle
s'inscrit alors il ya effectivement le
prg qui a une longue histoire politique
je suis pas sûr en fait qu'elle n'en
récupère exactement toutes les valeurs
produits mais en face moi je trouve que
anne hidalgo par exemple elle est la
candidate du parti socialiste le parti
socialiste a une très longue histoire
duquel elle s'en réclame le parti
communiste c'est exactement la même
chose l'écologie politique incarnée par
yannick jadot balilo sida une colonne
vertébrale qui est à peu près clair
la france insoumise bien sûr il a réduit
il a carrément un projet l'a effectué en
parlez en à une des propositions pour la
france
christine taubira
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle propose
elle a effectivement des valeurs elle
est humaniste elle le répète voilà sans
arrêt mais je ne sais pas d'une part
quelles sont ses propositions et quel
est son projet et dans quelle histoire
politique elle s'inscrit mais c'est
quand même très en pente douce et sur le
programme qui a été labourée par la
primaire pour le must est amusant
un point
qu'est ce qui la différencie d'anne
hidalgo mais sur le
fond celle de jean luc mélenchon aussi
et de yannick jadot c'est je partage
finalement un peu ce que vous dites là
l'instant elle est à la conjonction de
tous ces mouvements de gauche de toutes
ces familles de la gauche aujourd'hui et
peut-être que sa force c'est cela c'est
d'être celle qui peut en même temps
parler de transformation écologique de
justice sociale de participation
citoyenne et il se trouve que une
élection je suis plutôt pour une
évolution de nos institutions il faut
pouvoir incarner cela elle est au
carrefour finalement de ces familles est
peut-être que c'est ça qui la pousse
plus que d'autres la cantate du en même
temps l'accord d'une
famille politique qui a toujours indiqué
le préfet faisait prix mais les idées
sur les personnes c'est vraiment
particulière mais c'est à dire vous
pensez que françois mitterrand à
l'époque où lionel jospin il ne connaît
pas ou françois hollande il n'incarne
est pas un moment pour celles et ceux
qui ont été aux plus hautes
responsabilités
un certain nombre de courants de pensée
moi je ne crois pas que les idées vol
comme ça je me souvins 15 je pense que
lionel jospin pour le coup était très
structuré moi j'avais bien sûr je ne
referai pas le reproche à christiane
taubira d'avoir une diversité de lionel
jospin c'était assez injuste au fond que
ce soit ce soit tombé sur elle elle fait
perdre comme vous on a dit merci de
jean-pierre et surtout perdu par
lui-même parce qu'il avait il avait mené
une mauvaise campagne mais ce sera après
c'est vrai qu'elle a une image géante
elle a un charisme elle a une aura elle
est une sorte de talisman de de la
gauche pour pour certains mais d'un
point de vue de conquête électorale pour
l'instant
au parlement et en défendant à la fin
des temps mini de la justice
effectivement parce qu'elle a démontré
par ses récents fin il ya quand même des
choses r je ne suis pas à pas je n'aime
pas la campagne d'avant crise il faut
bien mais juste pour rappel en fait à
midi de la justice avec les réformes
qu'elle a mené pour qu'ils étaient quand
même qui disait des choses de sa vision
et puis le mariage mariage pour tous où
elle a quand même beaucoup ferraillé et
du coup ça c'est vrai que ça vous pose
aussi un personnage et c'est en plus
j'ai les lyrics et en plus elle est
ravie d'espoir dans les antilles c'est
là le bagout je me permets de dire
pendant les attentats aussi ou avec
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur à l'époque ils ont aussi et
avec le premier ministre et le président
enfin il fallait tenir au à ce moment-là
vous disais la gauche c'est
effectivement partie des mêmes problèmes
il ya plus d'idées alors combien tu dis
débat effectivement se reporte ce qui
est quand même aujourd'hui essentiel
dans la politique qui est l'incarnation
juste assez intéressant parce que vous
parliez du quinquennat de de françois
hollande dans lesquels elle a eu un rôle
quand même très important en tant que
garde des sceaux ce qui serait bien
c'est précisément quelles qu'elles
tirent un bilan en fait de ceux de ceux
de ce quinquennat et jusqu'à présent le
parti socialiste s'est toujours refusé à
le faire alors ils l'ont fait vraiment
avec parcimonie mais on sait toujours
pas très bien où ils en sont par rapport
à françois hollande on a vu anne hidalgo
qui allait voir françois hollande calais
l'écouté qui leurs tweets etc donc je
sais pas trop sur quel pied danser est
ce que l le renie complètement est ce
qu'elle dit c'est à cause de toi
françois si nous sommes dans cette
situation plus tard
christiane taubira christiane taubira
j'aimerais bien savoir comment elles
jugent globalement les autres réformes
vous parliez de ce qui s'est passé dans
le ministère de la justice se sont sous
sa férule mais il ya d'autres comme le
successeur avec les cantons son
successeur est arrivé il a dit que la
justice française était dans un état de
fraîcheur lisation voilà il ya aussi
tout ce qui se passe tout ce qui s'est
passé dans les autres ministères fin
jeudi la loi travail par exemple elle
était ministre lorsqu'il ya eu la loi
travail comment non pardon alors la loi
nâ qu'on la première loi macron par le
ballon de salle la fin de la première
heure macron elle était ministre qu'est
ce qu'elle en pense est ce que est ce
qu'elle trouve que c'est un succès
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu est ce qu
elle a dit au conseil ministre moi
j'aimerais bien savoir en fait et ça
allait cet aggiornamento va falloir
qu'elle le fasse un mot de réponse pour
conclure des noms enfin pas de réponse
là particulièrement on est dans un
moment qui est effectivement particulier
de l'histoire de notre pays de
l'histoire de la gauche ferait quand
même remarquer qu'il ya cinq ans à la
même époque
la campagne des manuels macron même s'il
était plus haut dans les sondages ne
s'est nouée que au moment où françois
bayrou l'a rejoint et à ce moment là il
ya eu un rassemblement
exprimé qui lui a permis de franchir un
certain cap nous sommes à la fin du mois
de janvier il ya cinq ans ce
rassemblement n'avait pas eu lieu donc
effectivement il y a le mois de février
qui va être très important pour cela et
on va voir surtout en dehors des états
majors politiques et des candidates et
candidats déclarés je crois que c'est
peut-être qui fait consensus entre nous
ici c'est de savoir comment les
françaises et les français vont
ressentir ce qui est en train de se
passer vont s'en saisir eux-mêmes aussi
et puis vous savez je termine juste là
dessus la grande force aussi de
christiane taubira c'est d'avoir un
collectif citoyen à côté d'elle qui
s'appelle avec taubira qui est encore en
fonctions depuis plus de deux ans
maintenant qu'ils sont des femmes et des
hommes qui ne sortent jamais investi
dans la sphère publique et qui depuis
hier et bien sont de nouveau
complètement engagé pour faire bouger
les lignes y compris dans leur propre
localité merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'avoir participé à ce débat très
bientôt sur sur public sénat